have you had people from the government
reach out to you about these aliens or
interdimensional beings is this
something that you feel like your life
is ever in danger the UFO topic is
considered by our government at a level
higher than weapons of mass destruction
have I ever been contacted dude of
course I mean I'm obtaining and
releasing military filmed footage
through leaks that comes to me they have
to do investigations they have to plug
leaks the scary thing to me is that
journalists get better briefings more
footage better understanding of some of
these UFO cases than our government uh
Representatives do so I've not been the
subject where I've been briefed often
times I have briefed on specific things
which is frightening there's got
to be people that have a better grasp on
this within our government